knock knock
you're stealing my vet i'll kill your
family
that's not how knock knock joke works
knock knock michael you don't do knock
knock jokes with russians because then
we have to knock at the door
turn down the tv you got to sit quiet
never hope they go away this is you
don't throw that back in the
land you know this it's triggered who's
there
i can't even do it now knock knock who's
there
leon leon who leon me when you're not
strong michael
well that will never happen i stole
elegantly eloquently that joke from you
the lie detector that was a lie
elegantly and eloquently
[Laughter]
yeah you crossed it on a sheet of paper
that means it's real
the reason i bring it up is because you
had the guts the brilliance
to to uh do a knock-knock joke
not once but three times with alex jones
i think it was like six i had a runner
okay maybe i just they started to sort
of uh
melt together in this beautiful art form
that you've created
which is like these kind loving
knock-knock jokes with alex jones
so you got the chance to meet him and
talk to them twice
with uh tim poole yeah in a long form
conversation what was it like
talking to alex jones both on the deep
philosophical intellectual level and
staring the man
in his eyes and doing a knock-knock joke
about
olive knock knock who's there olive i
love you alex i love you
well there's a lot to to explain where
do you start
i've been on his show in force a few
times when i was researching my book
then you write
so i had had conversations with him
before one of the things that i
appreciate about alex is he is a lot
more self-aware
than people think and has a good sense
of humor
and i also like a good twist ending
so if you set people up and all these
jokes are these kind of
vapid you know all of you jokes and the
last ones about building seven
uh they're not gonna see that one coming
nor will he see that one coming i even
had another one about sandy hook which i
didn't do on the air because he was
being
like a good sport so i didn't but that
was the dagger that was kind of behind
my back if necessary
but it was a good mechanism toward i
like it when things work on several
levels
it was also a good mechanism to keep
kind of the conversation
guarded and this every so often this is
kind of hitting the control
delete and bring it down uh um
to a certain point of calmness what
about the love thing
i mean you're saying that that was a
buildup to the dagger
but it was also somehow really
refreshing to get that little jolt like
that pause
you don't get that in conversations
often like i'm a huge fan of rogan
and he'll have a three-hour conversation
but at some point just
pause and be like i love you man
like like it's in the cheesiest way
possible
because that seems to be it somehow hits
the hardest then
i don't know i don't know you didn't
intend it that way but with alex jones
to sit there
and to say i love you
that was like that i just haven't never
heard that before
and so it struck me as like not just
funny for what you're doing
but just like whoa we just took because
uh conversations are all about like this
ranting especially with alex jones yeah
just like ranting about this or that
this
this part of the world like can you
believe this [ __ ] that kind of thing
but like to pause and be like this is
awesome i don't know if you felt that
way but
oh oh i definitely felt that way so it
was actually very fun i'll give you the
backstory of how that happened
um it was it was all
it was silly because tim calls me up and
there's this expression
in marketing don't go past the sale
right so if you're trying to sell
someone a car
and like it's got this feature this
feature and that feature and they're
like you know what i'm gonna buy the car
if you keep talking you can only make
them lose the sale
you just get them to sign and get get
out of dodge
so tim calls me up and he goes
okay uh here's what we're thinking this
is top secret alex is going to be on the
show
we want you on as well and i've never
said yes to anything as quickly in my
life
um and then he keeps talking and i'm
like tim this
you don't have to sell it i interrupted
him i go you don't have to sell it why
are you by the way
i think because um i am kind of an agent
of chaos
and alex is in his own way an agent of
chaos
and what is provides an opportunity in
this kind of news media space that you
and i travel in
it's the kind of things where none of us
three
you know as we said on the show knew
what it would be like
if you you know to certain within
certain parameters
what you know megyn kelly or wolf
blitzer
or any of these corporate figures are
going to be like in a conversation to
some extent
none of us had any idea and i knew they
didn't know i was bringing knock-knock
jokes
yeah um so that was kind of what was
so ex i said at one point i'm kind of
envious of the audience
because this is there's so many exciting
things that are happening and that the
internet
and podcasting provides people an
opportunity to do that
it was great yeah that that was the
greatest pairing with alex jones that
i've ever seen
by far so like oh okay so i immediately
knew now this isn't a knock on tim
but i don't even know if tim was
prepared
tim was not prepared for this call how
could he be prepared
well so i i mean i don't know if tim is
used to that i think joe rogan is more
equipped prepared for the chaos just the
years he's been in it
like i immediately thought this is the
right pairing for joe rogan because
alex jones has been on joe rogan a few
times
yeah three times my favorite so far was
with tim dillon right for jeff
yeah but tim was clearly uh tim dillon
was also kind of uh
a genius in his own right but he was
kind of a fan
and he was back and he was stepping away
he was almost like in awe of alex jones
where uh you were both
you were in awe of the experience that's
being created
and at the same time fearlessly just
trolling the situation
i mean to do a knock-knock joke to stop
me that just shows that
you're in control of the experience no
you're like riding the experience
that immediately was like this needs to
be on rogan
so i i hope that happens as well
you you're on your own of course on
rogan but just you that's an experience
that's the whatever this gotta be a good
name for it like jimi hendrix experience
there's the mic going out because that
was a band it's taken
well i don't know how many years you can
you can restart the
the experience because i feel so
interrupted i feel
a very big responsibility especially in
2020 to provide fun
and something cool and something unique
that hasn't been
done before for the audience i think
this has been a very rough year
on our audiences psychologically and in
other aspects of their lives
so i feel if i'm going to be there i'm
going to put on a show
and it's also going to be great because
it also alienates the people you don't
want
right so there's a lot of people who sit
there and be like oh he's telling not
people who are too cool for school uh
where they're like oh he's telling knock
knock jokes this is stupid i'm like good
if you have an issue with
having eaten cotton candy or doing a
puzzle
with a kid or without it you know by
yourself that's on you
and it's something very something i
think is the enemy of cynicism
and this idea that like oh this is too
silly and makes me like we need that
kind of
childlike aspect in our lives i think
it's something we could use more of
it's very much an aspect of our media
culture that to kind of have
be condemnatory about that or to do it
in a certain very corporate fake way
so it is something i encourage a lot
something i enjoy doing
um and again i like with the first time
i was on tim
i had a propeller beanie on you know
with the motorized and a lot of people
were like
i can't take anyone seriously who
dresses like this i go good
if you judge someone's ideas by how they
appear
instead of the ideas themselves you're
not someone i want
on my team
you